par delà cette absurdité essayant de
prendre un petit peu de recul et de
hauteur le débat qu'on a là sur
l'essentiel non essentiels il est
extrêmement important et il était
totalement tabou jusqu'à aujourd'hui
c'est par un hasard de l'histoire une
moquerie de la crise sanitaire qu'on en
vient à se poser cette question là parce
que dans une société de croissance d'une
société capitaliste
il ne faut surtout pas se poser la
question de ce qui est essentiel de ce
qui n'est pas essentiel quand on croit à
la croissance quand on croit au progrès
tout concourt au progrès même les choses
qui sont futiles font du bien être du
mieux être plus de richesses et sont
redistribuées autrement dit on peut dire
que la boîte de nuit qui n'est
évidemment qui ne paraît pas essentiel
qui est due la superficialité qui est de
l'amusement
à la fin elle finance le médicament est
là donc pas par le détour de cette
histoire sanitaire
on en vient à se poser la question que
les collapse haut c'est à dire ceux qui
croient à l'effondrement l'aider
croissanciste veulent poser depuis des
décennies puisque eux demandent à cor et
à cri que l'on fasse dans l'économie la
séparation du bon grain de l'ivraie
qu'on se pose la question de ce qui est
essentiel et ce qui n'est pas essentiel
et donc qu'on entre dans une autre
civilisation qui une civilisation
décroissance est encore une fois et ce
débat là on est en train de l'avoir
c'est ça qui est fou
[Musique]